you probably know the Beatles White
Album and Jay-Z's Black Album but do you
remember the gray album in 2004 producer
Danger Mouse combined the vocals from
The Black Album with samples from The
White Album to create a mashup of the
two
[Music]
this isn't the only time that the
world's best-selling band has collided
with hip-hop and R B back in 1987 krs-1
interpolated the Melody from Hey Jude on
the song Criminal minded we'll take the
wacky song and make it bad in the
Wu-Tang song The Heart Gently Weeps they
got George Harrison's son Danny to
recreate his dad's guitar riff
more recently Frank Ocean thanked The
Beatles for single-handedly getting him
out of his writer's block he even
sampled their song Here There and
Everywhere and his track white Ferrari
[Music]
ation